y aquí tenemos la molécula de butano
este es el carbono 1 carbono 2 carbono 3
y carbono 4 si observamos la molécula
desde el enlace entre el carbono 2 y 3
desde esta perspectiva así podemos ver
la conformación alternada del butano y
si rotamos el carbono frontal sin mover
el carbono de atrás obtenemos la
conformación eclipsada la deje un
poquito chueca para que puedan ver los
enlaces de atrás si rotamos nuevamente
pasamos de la conformación eclipsada a
la alternada y si la rotamos otros 60
grados obtenemos la conformación
eclipsada la girar e un poco para que
observen lo cerca que se encuentran los
grupos metilo incluso si los rotamos un
poco los hidrógenos chocan hay
impedimento estético pero regresemos a
la conformación eclipsada
rotamos nuevamente nos queda la
conformación alternada y si la volvemos
a rotar obtenemos la conformación
eclipsada que la dejó un poco chueca
para ver los enlaces de atrás si la
rotamos una vez más regresamos a la
conformación alternada
aquí tenemos el diagrama de energía para
las diferentes conformaciones que vimos
en el vídeo empezamos con la
conformación alternada que tiene una
cierta energía potencial y pasamos de
esta conformación alternada a esta
conformación eclipsada observen que se
necesita energía para pasar de una
conformación alternada a una eclipsada
la conformación eclipsada es más alta en
energía es menos estable porque
recuerden que a mayor energía potencial
la conformación es menos estable y a
menor energía potencial es más estable
así que la conformación alternada es más
estable que la eclipsada y la diferencia
de energía entre estas dos conformación
es este aproximadamente 16 kilos por mol
y los yoris
por mol entonces necesitamos energía
para pasar de esta conformación
alternada a esta eclipsada
pero cuando rotamos 60 grados la
conformación eclipsada pasamos a esta
conformación alternada observen que esta
conformación es un poco más alta en
energía que la primera y la diferencia
entre las dos con formaciones alternadas
es de aproximadamente 3.8 kilos por mont
3.8 kilos por mol ahora al pasar de esta
alternada a esta eclipsada necesitamos
energía y la diferencia es de
aproximadamente 19 kilos urss formol
19 kilos george por mol observen que
esta conformación eclipsada tiene una
energía más alta que ésta si dibujamos
una línea punteada podemos ver que hay
una diferencia de energía que es de
aproximadamente tres kilos urss por mol
entonces esta es la conformación
eclipsada menos estable porque tiene la
energía potencial más alta ahora de esta
conformación eclipsada pasamos a esta
alternada disminuye la energía potencial
y observen que esta conformación
alternada tiene la misma energía que
ésta si pasamos de esta conformación
alternada
eclipsada aumenta la energía pero
observen que esta conformación tiene la
misma energía que ésta así que podemos
dibujar una línea estas dos con
formaciones eclipsadas tienen la misma
energía y finalmente pasamos de esta
conformación eclipsada a la conformación
alternada que es menor en energía
analicemos las conformaciones con más
detalle empecemos con esta conformación
alternada del butano y vamos a enumerar
los carbonos este es el carbono 1 y está
unido al carbono 2 estamos viendo la
molécula desde el enlace entre el
carbono 2 y el carbono 3 recuerden que
en el vídeo no podíamos ver al carbono 3
porque nos tapa el carbono 2 pero cuando
dibujamos la proyección de newman
podemos representar el carbono de atrás
con un círculo
entonces este es el carbono 3 y
finalmente este es el carbono 4 ahora
hablemos del ángulo diedro que existe
entre este grupo metilo y este el ángulo
es de 180 grados espero que puedan verlo
el ángulo de yedro es de 180 grados a
esta conformación se le conoce como anti
y la conformación anti es baja en
energía potencial por lo tanto es la
conformación más estable del butano
debido a que estos grupos voluminosos
están lo más alejados posible además
nuestros enlaces están alternados todo
eso la convierte en la conformación más
estable ahora sí en la conformación anti
rotamos el carbono frontal 60 grados sin
mover el carbono de atrás obtenemos
la conformación que es una conformación
eclipsada este enlace está eclipsado con
este y este hidrógeno está eclipsado con
este hidrógeno no los dibuje
completamente eclipsados para que puedan
ver lo que ocurre en uno de los vídeos
anteriores dijimos que la energía de un
par de hidrógenos eclipsados es de 4
kilos urss por mol kilo jules formol y
también dijimos que la energía de un
grupo metilo eclipsado con un hidrógeno
es de aproximadamente 6 kilos por mol
kilo jules por mol que es la misma
situación que tenemos aquí abajo un
hidrógeno y un grupo metilo eclipsados
así que también tienen una energía de
seis kilos jules formol
si sumamos las energías 4-6 es igual a
10 6 es igual a 16 observen que esa es
la diferencia entre estas dos con
formaciones 16 kilos por mol entonces
esta conformación eclipsada es más alta
en energía potencial ahora analicemos la
otra conformación eclipsada ésta tiene
la energía potencial más alta por lo
tanto es la conformación menos estable
del butano observen que tenemos un par
de hidrógenos eclipsados tienen una
energía de 4 kilos por mol por acá
tenemos otro par de hidrógenos
eclipsados así que tenemos otros cuatro
kilos urss por mol y luego tenemos dos
grupos metilo estos enlaces están
alineados tenemos dos grupos metilo
clips
2 cuál será la energía cuando un grupo
metilo está eclipsado con otro bueno
podemos calcularlo porque sabemos que la
energía total es de 19 kilos jules por
mol entonces como esto no lo sabemos
es nuestra x si sumamos todo nos debe
dar un total de 19 entonces si tenemos 4
4 x 4 + 4 + x es igual a 19 y claro
x es igual a 11 11 kilos por mol esa es
la energía de un grupo metilo eclipsado
con otro metilo observen que aquí hay
impedimento estético tal como lo vimos
en el vídeo
incluso los hidrógenos de estos grupos
metilo chocan entre sí y eso
desestabiliza entonces si aumentamos el
impedimento éste
con eso desestabiliza la conformación
así que la conformación eclipsada tiene
la energía potencial más alta es la
menos estable esta conformación
eclipsada tiene más energía potencial
que ésta debido a que estos grupos
metilo están muy cerca finalmente
echemos un vistazo a esta conformación
alternada observen que esta conformación
tiene una energía más alta que la
conformación anti si analizamos el
ángulo de yedro entre los grupos metilo
podemos ver que es de 60 grados y a esto
le llamamos conformación goals lo
escribiré se escribe ghanuchi pero se
pronuncia goes la conformación goes es
un poco más alta en energía que la
conformación anti
porque estos grupos metilo se encuentran
más cerca hay impedimento estético los
hidrógenos de estos grupos están muy
cerca en la conformación goes y eso
tiene un efecto desestabilizante por lo
tanto hay un poco más de energía
potencial en esta conformación pero como
la conformación coach es una
conformación alternada es más estable
que las conformaciones eclipsadas aunque
no es tan estable como la conformación
anti porque estos grupos metilo están
cerca